[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin am zweiten Weihnachtstag in
allen einen schönen guten Abend Christin
hat später britischen weihnachtsfußball
und Handball so ist es einen schönen
guten Abend auch von mir dann blicken
wir gemeinsam auf unsere Themen
Tote und schwer Kranke Ausnahmezustand
auf den Intensivstationen in China
leiden Millionen unter der massiven
corona-welle
der Krieg in der Ukraine tobt weiter
auch an Weihnachten schwierige fechte im
Osten und wieder ein Angriff auf einen
Militärstützpunkt in Russland
und Überraschung in der Premier League
Underdog Newcastle stürmt nach einem
Sieg über läster auf Platz 2 der
englischen Liga
nach fast drei corona-jahren in
Deutschland und etlichen corona-regeln
und Debatten darüber hält Christian
Drosten die Pandemie bei uns für beendet
in der Bevölkerung gebe es inzwischen
eine breite Immunität wodurch das Virus
im Sommer kaum noch durchkommen könnte
sagt der Chef Virologe der Berliner
Charité dem Tagesspiegel völlig anders
und viel dramatischer die Situation in
China allein in den ersten drei
Dezemberwochen sollen sich dort 248
Millionen Menschen mit Corona infiziert
haben so chinesische Schätzungen
offiziell bestätigt ist das nicht die
tatsächlichen Infektionszahlen dürften
aber wohl noch weit höher liegen sagen
Experten weltweit aus Peking Elisabeth
Schmidt
es ist der Versuch dem Patientenansturm
irgendwie Herr zu werden diese Klinik in
Peking bietet ab sofort auch
online-sprechstunden an doch es kommen
immer noch bis zu 600 Menschen pro Tag
in die Notaufnahme
wir behandeln rund um die Uhr permanent
passen wir unsere Sprechstunde an die
aktuelle Situation an
seit gestern werden Infektionszahlen
nicht mehr zentral veröffentlicht die
Verantwortung liegt jetzt bei einer
untergeordneten Behörde und bei den
Provinzen doch die erfassen kovetfälle
sehr unterschiedlich von einigen wenigen
bis zu einer millioneninfektionen pro
Tag alles dabei manchmal werden
asymptomatische Fälle dazu gezählt
manchmal nicht Chaos bei der Corona
Statistik die große Erzählung von sie
sind irgendwas
überlegene System und diese Erzählung
ist natürlich ihnen zerschossen worden
jetzt sondern es ist also klar dass das
China die Kontrolle verloren hat das ist
im Grunde preisgeben musste ja alle die
Maßnahmen die man über zweieinhalb Jahre
gefahren hatte statt 0 Co wird jetzt
vollkoid und doch dürfen Chinesinnen und
Chinesen nach wie vor keine westlichen
backsine erhalten ihnen werden die
gleichen Impfstoffe gespritzt wie vor
drei Jahren
immer wieder beschwichtig die
Staatsführung eigene an Omicron
angepasste Impfstoffe befinden sich in
der Entwicklung auch auf den Markt
geschafft hat es bislang keiner es ist
ein letztes beharrliches Festhalten am
eigenen chinesischen Weg die
Staatsregierung spielt auf Zeit und mit
100.000 Menschen leben
in den sozialen Medien machen inzwischen
immer mehr Videos wie diese die Runde
lange Schlangen vor Krematorien hunderte
Tote einige wurden schnell in Paketboxen
gelegt
ja und nach dem Ende der Null
corona-politik im Inland lockert China
jetzt auch die Regeln an der Grenze ab
dem 8 Januar müssen Einreisende nicht
mehr in Quarantäne dann reicht ein
negativer corona-test ja es ist eine
Machtdemonstration Chinas gegenüber
Taiwan Peking hat erneut eine große
Militärübung abgehalten und 71 Kampfjets
und Drohnen sowie sieben Schiffe in die
umstrittene Taiwanstraße nahe der Insel
beordert offenbar weil die USA neue
Militärhilfen für Taiwan beschlossen
haben aus Sicht der Insel Republik war
es die bisher größte Verletzung des
eigenen Luftraums durch die chinesische
Luftwaffe
im ukrainekrieg ist die russische
Luftwaffe hoch überlegen schaffen es
ukrainische Drohnen in russischen
Luftraum ist das Aufsehen erregend
offenbar hat es wieder eine Attacke auf
den russischen Militärstützpunkt
engelsgegeben 600 km von der Grenze
entfernt nach Angaben moskauz wurde dort
eine ukrainische Drohne abgeschossen
drei Soldaten sollen durch Trümmerteile
getötet worden sein Christian Volk
berichtet
es dauert nur wenige Sekunden
festgehalten auf einer
Überwachungskamera eine Explosion auf
dem russischen Militärstützpunkt Engels
offenbar konnte die ukrainische Drohne
erst im letzten Moment abgeschossen
werden der Stützpunkt liegt mehrere
hundert Kilometer im Landesinneren
das sind die Konsequenzen der russischen
Aggressionen falls die Russen dachten
der Krieg würde sie im tiefen Hinterland
nicht betreffen dann irren Sie sich
es ist Kriegstag 360 in der Ukraine doch
im umkämpften bachmut haben Sie schon
lange aufgehört zu zählen die Stadt an
der Front ist mittlerweile eine Festung
seit Wochen versucht Russland sie
einzunehmen
die Situation in der Stadt es ist sehr
laut ständig explodiert etwas doch wir
müssen überleben und wir werden
überleben
viele Soldaten auf beiden Seiten
überleben die Kämpfe um den
Verkehrsknotenpunkt bachmut nicht jeden
Tag so die Schätzungen sterben dutzende
um die Verletzten Ukrainer kümmert sich
Sanitäter olexi mit seinen Kollegen für
sie ist das mehr als ein Job sagen Sie
es ist eine Lebensaufgabe
eigentlich dachte ich dass über die
Feiertage eine festliche Stimmung
herrschen wird aber weit gefehlt wir
haben es weiter jeden Tag mit dem Leid
der Menschen zu tun der ukrainische
Präsident befürchtet dass es auch in den
kommenden Tagen neue russische Angriffe
mit Raketen und Drohnen geben wird dann
müssen olexi und seine Kollegen wohl
wieder ausrücken so wie jeden Tag
eiskalte Weihnacht für viele in den USA
die Zahl der Todesopfer durch den
Wintersturm Elliot ist auf mindestens 37
gestiegen betroffen vor allem der
Nordosten des Landes die Temperaturen
lagen in vielen Bundesstaaten weit unter
minus 20 Grad hinzu kam heftiger
Schneefall
hunderttausende Haushalte waren
zeitweise ohne Strom tausende Flüge
mussten gestrichen werden
Personalmangel und extrem hohe
Krankenstände verschärfen die Situation
in vielen deutschen Kliniken häufig
werden Patienten nicht mehr aufgenommen
bzw abgewiesen deswegen waren über
Weihnachten die Befürchtungen in den
Notaufnahmen entsprechend groß aber
zumindest den Kiel hatte man trotz
angespannter Lage die Situation gut im
Griff hier in einer Hebestreit und jetzt
zeigt
und da haben die Airbags ausgelöst
Oberarzt die haben Niklas käsebaum muss
doch über Weihnachten dafür sorgen dass
Patienten in Kiel schnell geholfen wird
Notarzt kündigt einen Autofahrer an der
am Steuer seines Wagens
zusammengebrochen sein soll
also der Helikopter Notarzt ist
hingeflogen wird ihn aber muss sie nicht
fliegen sondern würde ihn dann sozusagen
Boden gebunden mehr transportieren
der Autofahrer auf den sie warten ist
nur einer von etwa 100 Patienten die in
diesem Weihnachtstag in der Notaufnahme
behandelt werden müssen längst nicht
immer geht es um akute Lebensgefahr
ich hatte einen kleinen Unfall und habe
mir den Finger gebrochen neben
Unfallopfern sind es auch Patienten mit
Atemwegserkrankungen die in die
Notaufnahme kommen an atemnotleitende
Kinder sind jetzt aber kaum noch dabei
hat abgenommen das ist ein gutes Zeichen
das war aber auch zu erwarten und
Patienten mit Atemnot und letztendlich
atmestörung gehören ja Moment unter
Corona aber auch unter Grippe ganz klar
zu den Kandidaten die wir sehen und mal
laufen sich hinein und mal kommen Sie
mit uns inzwischen hat der Rettungswagen
mit dem verunglückten Autofahrer die
Klinik erreicht dem Schockraum wird
klarer was den Patienten passiert sein
könnte am ehesten wird er an
Schlaganfall erlitten haben gerade als
er mit dem Auto losgefahren es ist in
Grab gefahren das heißt wir haben
erstmal ähm in der körperlichen
Untersuchung und auch mit einem
Ultraschall erstmal große körperliche
Verletzung ausgeschlossen in der Kieler
Uniklinik geben sie sich alle Mühe dass
das Not leidende Gesundheitssystem auch
an den Feiertagen funktioniert
die Kirchen sind nach dem Start der
größte Arbeitgeber in Deutschland und
dürfen im Arbeitsrecht eigene Wege gehen
für die rund 800.000 Angestellten der
katholischen Kirche und der Caritas
konnte das bislang enorme
Einschränkungen bedeuten wer nach einer
Scheidung wieder heiratete oder in einer
gleichgeschlechtlichen Partnerschaft
lebte dem drohte die Kündigung und das
ändert sich jetzt die katholischen
Bischöfe haben das kirchliche
Arbeitsrecht reformiert im Bistum Köln
gilt die Neuregelung ab dem 1 Januar
dort erfährt aber berichtet
seit langem arbeitet Carolin Balzer bei
einem katholischen Träger in Köln und
seit langem liebt Balzer eine Frau sie
haben ein gemeinsames Kind richtig
schwierig wurde es als Balzer ihre
Partnerin heiraten wollte ich hatte
Herzklopfen und wenn das Generalvikariat
sagte hier da lebt eine Frau lesbisch
will auch noch eine Lebenspartnerschaft
und hat auch noch ein Kind wie könnt ihr
diese Mitarbeiterin in euren reinhalten
bislang war für die katholische Kirche
eine gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe oder eine
widerheirat ein Kündigungsgrund vor gut
einem Jahr protestierten dagegen viele
Schwule und lesbisch lebende Kirchen
Mitarbeitende mit der Initiative auch
den church die Deutsche
Bischofskonferenz reagiert und will das
Arbeitsrecht ändern
all diese Fragen gerade was die sexuelle
Orientierung angeht spielen in diesem
Arbeitsrecht keine Rolle mehr wir sind
hier konform mit der EU
Antidiskriminierungsrichtlinie für uns
ist wichtig dass man sich mit der dem
Arbeitgeber Kirche identifiziert dass
man die Ziele mitträgt die Bistümer
müssen diese Änderung zwar noch umsetzen
aber allein die Ankündigung löst große
Erleichterung bei dem Betroffenen aus
für mich persönlich ist es jetzt
sozusagen das was ich mir immer
gewünscht habe nämlich so leben zu
können wie ich lebe im Privaten ohne
dass ich Angst haben muss rechtlich von
der Kirche belangt zu werden für Balzer
war es Glück offen lesbisch lebend
weiter beim katholischen Träger arbeiten
zu dürfen künftig soll es einfach ihr
recht sein
und eine gute Nachricht aus Österreich
nach dem Lawinenabgang am Arlberg in
Österreich konnten alle vermissten
gerettet werden ursprünglich waren die
Einsatzkräfte von zehn verschütteten
Wintersportlern ausgegangen sechs von
ihnen sein aber nicht von der Lawine
erfasst worden teilte die Polizei mit
der Suche und Rettungseinsatz wurde am
späten Abend beendet
der Sport gibt es tatsächlich auch am
zweiten Weihnachtsfeiertag Christine
in der Premier League wird ja
traditionell gespielt eine Art Geschenk
an die Fußballfans seit mehr als 150
Jahren und eine schöne Bescherung gab es
für Newcastle United 3:0 bei Leicester
City vorläufig Tabellenplatz 2
die WM-Pause kam für das Team von Eddie
hau eigentlich ungelegen davor fünf Liga
Siege nacheinander doch Newcastle hat
seine Top-Form konserviert noch keine
zwei Minuten gegen läster vorbei und
strittiges faul von Amati am Ex
Hoffenheimer Elfmeter wurde läuft an die
frühe Führung für den Favoriten der in
der Anfangsphase nicht zu stoppen ist
ein iron die Marie ich und wieder ein
Miron hervorragende Kombination zum 2:0
in der 7 Minute 8 Todes paraguayas in
den letzten neuen Premier League Partien
der 13 lässt hat zuletzt enorm anfällig
bei ruhenden Bällen die Gäste wissen
auch das zu nutzen Jolin Turner zieht
das 3:0 nach einer guten halben Stunde
in der zweiten Halbzeit drosselt der
Favorit das Tempo und Gerät ein einziges
Mal in Bedrängnis fast das Eigentor in
der 61 Minute es bleibt beim 13:0
Newcastle verdrängt Manchester City
vorerst von Platz 2
Deutschland handballmeister SC Magdeburg
hat sich mit einem Sieg in die WM-Pause
verabschiedet 33 zu 29 gegen Frisch Auf
Göppingen und hält als dritter bei zwei
Spielen weniger Anschluss an die
Tabellenspitze tolle Kulisse und bestes
Hochsommerwetter zum Start der 77 Sydney
hubertrecker 109 Yachten machten sich
auf den Weg darunter die Berliner Brüder
Axel und Peter Baumgarten als einzige
deutsche Kuh 628 Seemeilen müssen
entlang der Südostküste Australiens
bewältigt werden Richtung Ziel in der
Bucht vor Hubert in Tasmanien und wenn
alles gut geht Ankunft bereits morgen
sieht ja schick aus vielen Dank
Christine und das Jahr geht jetzt zu
Ende und wir haben zum Schluss noch mal
einige Bilder die 2022 geprägt haben da
waren die Olympischen Spiele in Peking
umstritten und ganz im Zeichen der
corona-pandemie kurz darauf die ersten
Bomben auf Kiel seitdem herrscht Krieg
in der Ukraine und die spüren Millionen
weltweit im Sommer mussten die Briten
nach 70 Jahren von ihrer Queen Abschied
nehmen aber es gab auch ausgelassene
Momente wie etwa in München wo nach zwei
Jahren corona-pause wieder auf dem
Oktoberfest gefeiert wurde
[Musik]
Album 2022 Bilder eines Jahres gleich
nach unserer Sendung das ganz komplette
Bild für Sie jetzt zum Wetter ganz im
Norden einzelne Schauer an den Alpen
anfangs Regen über 1000 Meter Schnee
sonst meist trocken im Norden frischer
Winter in Küsten stürmische Böden die
Höchstwerte zwischen drei und neun Grad
um viertel vor zwölf bringt Sie
Christopher Wehrmann mit heute Express
wieder auf den Stand der Dinge schönen
Dank schönen Weihnachtsabend und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]